Hey, herzlich. Oder Fussballer, die natürlich wesentlich besser spielen können, irgendwann vom Verständnis her, aber körperlich den Verschleiss mit sich ziehen. Wie dieser Typ. Ich habe eine Doku gesehen über so einen Typen. Ich habe auch schon viele Dokus über Typen gesehen. Und dessen Aufgabe war es, den ganzen Tag von morgens bis abends, der hat bei einer Rüstungsschmiede gearbeitet, also ich glaube heutzutage nennt man das anders, bei Heckler und Koch oder sowas, und die haben Pistolen hergestellt und die haben die Läufe hergestellt, also das sind die Rohre, wo dann die Kaventsmänner durchgefreakt werden mit Karacho.
Ich glaube, in jeder anderen Wortkommandat hat es nicht verstanden, was du meinst, aber Gott sei Dank sprichst du meine Sprache als einer.
Und ja, die müssen ja sehr gerade sein, also wahnsinnig gerade diese Läufe.
Da darf kein Hubbel drin sein.
Damit die Projektile, also ein Knödel oder auf gar keinen Fall.
Nee.
Und dessen Aufgabe war es, die anzuschauen und wirklich durchzugucken, ob die gerade sind und dann wirklich so ganz präzise.
Also die Maschine stellt ja schon sehr gerade her.
Aber er guckt dann nochmal durch und so mit so einem kleinen Hämmerchen und so ganz genau.
Und dann sagt, haben die das Interview, dann meint er so, ja, ich bin jetzt 50 oder so und ich habe in meinem Leben irgendwie sechs neue Brillen gebraucht. Ich brauche immer stärkere Brillen, weil meine Augen einfach kaputt gehen, weil ich jeden Tag ganz präzise da dieses Rohrendank gucken muss und er meinte auch, er sei der Einzige, so wenn er jetzt stirbt, dann gibt es das einfach nicht mehr, Leute, die halt in diese Rohre gucken. Man hat Waffen und Deutschland als Kriegslandationen ein riesen Problem. Ja, die ballern irgendwo hin, aber nicht auf den Feind. Aber das denke ich mir auch so, wenn du dir diesen Job annimmst und merkst, oh, ich brauche eine Brille, und dann machst du zwei Jahre weiter und ich brauche noch eine Brille, würde ich sagen, hör auf an dem Punkt, weil du hast einen ganz klaren Trend an dem Punkt. Aber das ist auch so ein bisschen pseudowissenschaftlich. Ich meine, du kannst eine klare Ursache-Wirkung-Relation herstellen, wenn du jetzt irgendwo tief im Schacht arbeitest und die ganze Zeit so Kohle einatmest und halt schwarz hustest. Dann kann man sagen, okay, möglicherweise liegt dein Husten an deinem Job. Aber wohingegen bei diesem Kucken, also vielleicht einfach sehr schlechte Augen. Manche Leute brauchen halt alle zwei Jahre eine Kunde. Glaubst du, dass der Mann einen Job hat, wo er den ganzen Tag gucken muss und dann ist sein Kucken nicht so gut? Ist das sein Job? Ja, der ist der professionelle Gucker. Ich habe mir jetzt den Gag verkniffen, dass er professionell in die Röhre guckt. Aber auch den gebe ich euch mit, liebe Freunde. Hey, Florentin, hey, verknallt du keine Gags, okay? Ja, manchmal bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Aber das müssen wir ja nicht machen, wir sind doch unter uns. Aber dieser Job widerspricht allem, was ich über Waffen zu denken glaube. Weil, überleg mal, in einem Film nehmen die einfach in so Zombie-Apokalypse-Welt. So nach 800 Jahren kommt jetzt im Bunkel raus und dann finden die eine Waffe. Überall im Film finden die ja Waffen und schießen dann damit. Ja. So, die Chance, dass da kein Hubbel drin ist, keine kleine Unebenheit, Nübel, ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, weil die ja mal irgendwo doll runtergefallen ist oder so. Ja, ich gehe davon aus, dass das dann sehr geringe Unpräzisionen dann erzeugt. Das heißt, dein Job ist nicht mehr wichtig. Aber wenn die aus der Fabrik kommen, dann müssen die ja topnotch sein. Heißt aber, sein Job ist nicht mehr so richtig wichtig. Heißt, er hat sein Augenlicht, verliert er jetzt aus irgendeinem kleinen Grund. Es ist wahrscheinlich irgendein Onkel, der angestellt wurde mit, ja guck die Liga nochmal an, die wir in unfassbar präzisen Maschinen jeden Tag herstellen. Hey, kennst Onkel Hermann, brauch nochmal einen Job. Kannst du nicht was machen in einer Waffenfirma. Ja komm, wir bestellen einen als Profituellen Gucker. Ihr hört das Podcast UFO mit Stefan Tietze und Florentin Will. Wir haben eine Woche Osterpause gemacht, die grossen Osterferien haben wir uns genossen. Ich fand's, wir nehmen gerade sehr früh auf, wir müssen noch vorm Dreh aufnehmen, weil mittlerweile Stefan Titzer hat einen vollgepackten Tagesplan mittlerweile und wir müssen jetzt schon ganz früh morgens aufstehen, um extra für euch Podcasts zu holen. Es ist drei Uhr morgens, es ist ganz früh morgens, aber ich glaube, das tut uns mal ganz gut, so ein bisschen frischer Wind rein. Du hast gerade von Leuten gesprochen, die Schlepptop sagen. Lass uns mal Leute einfach definieren, so heute mal die Leute-Folge. Ich weiss nicht, wie es das bei dir ist, aber ich ordne primär Leute in Schubladen ein aufgrund ihres Aussehens. Also ich habe diese, die sahen so aus wie meine Grundschullehrerin, da habe ich einen ganzen Haufen Leute, die aussahen wie meine Grundschullehrerin. Also Archetypen. Unter anderem Kristen Wig. Also die wirkt exakt, so ein paar Leute, die einfach so aussehen wie meine Grundschullehrerin. Dann, ich weiß nicht, warum ich diese Gruppe habe, dann paar Leute, die aussehen wie meine Tante. Aber so Bezugsleute stehen oben drüber und darunter ordnen die Leute ein. Und es ist wie so ein Koordinatensystem, wo man Leute so einordnet. Aber es gibt auch Leute, die uns und andere sagen, Schlepptop und Teflon, die fallen da raus. Die kommen in ihre eigenen... Aber warum Teflon? Das verstehe ich nicht ganz. Statt was? Telefon. Ach, statt Telefon. Das sagt kein Mensch. Wirklich? Einen Haufen, ein Dutzend, Leute. Wir können hier eine neue Rubrik aufmachen. Die Art von Menschen der Woche. Die Art von Menschen der Woche. Wo wir jede Woche eine neue Art von Menschen vorstellen. Und das ist jetzt gar nicht gewertet. Weder positiv noch negativ. Wir sagen nicht, die sollen vergast werden. Wir sagen auch nicht, die sollen einen Preis bekommen. Wir sagen aber auch nicht, die sollen nicht vergast werden. Ja, richtig. Wir sagen lediglich, dass die existieren und dann macht ihr damit mal, was ihr wollt. Mein Art von Menschen der Woche ist Menschen, zum Beispiel stell dir vor, du bist Journalist. Kann ich mir nicht so gut vorstellen. Stell dir vor, du hast Bachelor in Journalistik. Wow. So, und jetzt schreibst du auf Twitter in deiner Twitter-Bio, da hast du ja immer so drei Begriffe, so wie du dich selber definierst. Aber du schreibst nicht Journalist, sondern du schreibst sowas wie Fragensteller. Oder Watchdog. Du schreibst sowas wie Fragensteller.
Ja, statt Journalist.
Diese Art von Menschen ist meine Art von Menschen der Woche.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du dir was darunter vorstellen kannst,
aber diese Art von Menschen, die, ja, die Fragensteller schreiben würden.
Ich finde Fragensteller und sowas wie Watchdog oder irgendwie Dreckaufwühler oder sowas.
Ja, ja, genau. Das ist auch nicht so uncool. Ja, aber die dann immer so auch überdeutsche Begrwühler oder sowas. Ja, genau.
Aber die dann immer so auch überdeutsche Begriffe wählen für sowas,
aber die dann auch so eine gewisse Bescheidenheit haben,
so, ich nenne mich nicht
Autor, ich nenne mich Geschichtenerzähler.
Die an Geschichtenerzähler
drinstehen, wo ich denke, es ist dasselbe.
Es ist genau dasselbe, es ist einfach
ein anderes, du sagst ja wenigstens aus, aber
sie sagen in gewisser Weise trotzdem was aus, nämlich, dass sie Arschlöcher sind. Aber es ist ein anderes Thema.
Ja, das stimmt. Das ist korrekt. Meine Art der Menschen der Woche ist neben, also natürlich um die Publik aufzumachen, Leute die sagen Teflon, Leute die sagen Schlepptop. Was hatte ich eben noch? Zum Bleistift? Wow, danke, zum Bleistift. Das sind diese diese Art älterer Mensch, die immer noch glauben, das wäre modern und sie würden wie die Jugend sprechen.
Das wären die Begriffe der Jugend, mit denen sie anknüpfen können. Das wohnt mich seit langem, auf jeden Fall.
Und um dann nochmal ein bisschen vom Werk zu kommen, Leute, die zum Beispiel auf diesen Stühlen sitzen, die wir gerade haben, diese Bürostühle, generell Leute, die die Gegenstände auf ein Mindestmaß an Funktionen reduzieren.
Dieser Stuhl kann hoch, runter, du kannst damit rumfahren, rechts und links, drehen, wirbeln, drehen, wirbeln und du kannst aber auch unten diesen Hebel betätigen, indem du einstellen kannst, zum einen einstellen kannst, dass er nach hinten ausweicht, das heißt, du kannst ein bisschen schaukeln, dann wie stark der nach hinten ausweicht und wie viel Kraft du auch wenden musst. Und das ist eine ganz tolle Funktion und die nutzen die meisten Menschen nicht. Die meisten Menschen setzen sich drauf und tun nichts damit. Ich finde es aber auch die unangenehmste Situation, wenn du mit einer fremden Person gegenüber sitzt, die auch auf so einem Bürostuhl sitzt und dir dann sowas sagt wie, wie kann man denn da die Lehne verstellen und dann fängt man an gemeinsam zwischen den Beinen der Person, die man nicht gut kennt, rumzufummeln und einfach willkürlich irgendwelche Hebel zu ziehen, weil allein schon die Tatsache, dass du deinen Stuhl verstanden hast, ist unwahrscheinlich und dann musst du es nochmal drehen im Kopf, zu wissen, ah, was bei mir rechts ist, ist bei dir links und dann musst du halt einfach überall rumfummeln. Ich fürchte mich auch vor dem Moment, wo mein Kind mich fragt, ob ich die Schleife zu machen kann.
Ja, schwierig. Aber muss man ja gar nicht machen. Ich hatte lange Zeit eine Hose an. Eine Hose an. Ich erinnere mich kaum noch an die Zeit. Aber warte mal, wenn du eine Hose hast und dann hast du in der rechten Hand einen Teil, Also du machst dann die Hose an. Eine Hose an. Jetzt, ich erinnere mich kaum noch an die Zeit. Aber warte mal, wenn du eine Hose hast und dann hast du in der rechten Hand einen Teil, also du machst die Hose vorne zu, ist dann der Teil der rechten Hand näher am Bauch als der der linke oder andersrum?
Der rechte ist näher am Bauch.
Ja.
So, ich hatte nämlich mal eine Hose, wo das andersrum war und dann habe ich immer gefragt, warum ist das so, warum ist das so, was soll das, was soll das, was soll das? Und irgendjemand, ich glaube mein Vater war es, oder irgendjemand hat dann gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wer es war, aber irgendjemand hat dann gesagt, das ist eine Hose für Frauen, da ist das andersrum. Da ist die linke Hand näher am Bauch, also da kommt dann an der linken Seite der Knopf und die rechte Hand kommt drüber. Warum sollte das anders sein? Jemals. Und dann und dann, ich weiß nicht, wer es war, aber dann hat die Selbperson gesagt, damit die Geschlechter sich die gegenseitig gut an und ausziehen können. Bitte, was ist los? Dass das, was du an dir gelernt hast, du einfach nur eins zu eins übertragen musst auf die weibliche Hose. Bitte! Aber ich dachte mir schon damals als sieben... Warum hat man nicht einfach so ein Klettverschluss? Ja, oder so ein Reissverschluss. Aber ich dachte mir auch schon... Einfach so... Ich dachte mir damals schon als Siebenjähriger, dachte mir, das ist weird. Das ist strange. Vor allem unabhängig davon, warum ich jetzt eine Frauenhose anhab, die ganz anders ist. Moment, das ist der spannende Aspekt der Geschichte auch eigentlich. Was ist da denn passiert? Ich glaube, es war so eine kurze Hose. Eineangerschaftshose, wenn du zu fett warst. So eine Stretchhose. Es ist ja sogar, also bei Kindern ist ja sowieso die Geschlechtermode relativ egal, glaube ich. Aber die Körper ja auch nicht so gut unterscheiden. Bis du gemobbt wirst von der Wurstthekenfrau, die dich fragt, ist das ein Junge oder ein Mädchen? Dann bist du da hin, bist du cool, alles super, wow, hast du coole Kinder bis da hin. Ich habe mit meiner Mutter Kleidung gekauft bei irgendeinem Secondhand-Flüchtlingsding oder sowas. Und da habe ich tatsächlich, weil ich hasse Schuhe einkaufen und Kleidung einkaufen, deswegen segne ich alles sofort ab. So jeder Vorschlag, ja machen wir, machen wir, ich will hier nur weg und wieder super smart Radio spielen. Und machen wir einfach weg. Und dann hatte ich am Ende ohne Witz, hatte ich ich Stiefel mit Absatz. Jetzt nicht mit High Heels. Aber du sagst, du hast gerade das Wort Absegnen benutzt. Heißt, kamen Leute mit Klemmbrett zu dir, die dann kurz irgendwie Bestätigung wollen. Wer bietet dir denn Absatzschuhe an? Meine Mutter, wenn du mit deinen Eltern einkaufen gehst, dann sagen die, ja, darf das genehm sein, der Herr. Und du sagst, ach ja, bitteschön. Na, Moment mal, aber so weit kommt es aber nicht, dass sie die Abstandsschuhe anbietet. Naja, also wenn ich von Abstandsschuhen rede, dann meine ich jetzt keine High Heels, sondern halt die einfach einen gewissen Absatz haben. Hast du auch den Stift für deine Lippen abgesegnet? Hast du auch das, wir machen dein Gesicht ein bisschen schöner, Puder abgesegnet? Meine Eltern wollten halt eine Tochter haben, so, und das kann ich ihr nicht verübeln. Hast du auch dieses etwas zu langen Pullover abgesegnet, wo du keine Hose noch mehr anziehen musst? Hast du das alles abgesegnet? Ja, habe ich alles abgesegnet. Und dann kam ich echt eines Tages, aber ungelogen hatte ich dann auch einen Mantel bekommen, der länger war. Kleid, das war offensichtlich. Da war ich in der Schule und dachte mir so, ich habe mir keinen Hauch von Gedanken darüber gemacht
und bin auf die Schule gestöckelt und dachte mir so, Moment mal, ich sehe richtig bescheuert.
Und alle Lehrer, gut, Florentin, das müsst ihr respektieren, der will jetzt ein Mädchen sein.
Nein, ich dachte mir so, Alter, verdammt. Aber unabhängig davon. Also, du bin nicht am Motto-Tag, wo plötzlich Geschlechtertausch ist und du dann plötzlich wie so eine Frau auf den Schulhof wackelst mit so grossen High-Eals. Aber es war ganz merkwürdig und ich habe da dann auch gemerkt, oh scheiße, ich habe einen grossen Fehler gemacht. Ich hätte das nicht einfach so absiegen sollen. Ich hätte mir da schon ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht. Aber mit dieser Hose, ist das wirklich so? Ich meine, kannst du denn... Vielleicht ist es ja wirklich so, dass Frauenhosen anders sind. Ich habe da jetzt Angst, dass ich mich ein bisschen verrenne. Ja, ich habe auch ein bisschen... In Wissen, dass das nicht stimmt. Sowohl Wissen als auch Unwissen. Ich bin mir gerade unsicher, kann gut sein. Ich weiß nur, dass bei Männern der, du hast ja dann, wie gesagt, rechts ist näher am Bauch, links ist weiter weg, du machst die Hose auf und dann hast du ja quasi, es ist ja asymmetrisch im Schritt, weil du hast ja an der einen Stelle den Reißverschluss und dann hast du ja dieses, ich zeige das jetzt mal an meinem Schritt, das ist ja asymmetrisch. Das ist ja asymmetrisch. Das liegt daran, weil die meisten Menschen, die meisten Männer Linksträger sind, ist es so rumgeschnitten. Deswegen hast du außen, das ist links, weiter weg vom Geschlecht als rechts, damit links mehr Platz ist, weil die meisten Männer Linksträger sind. Rechts ist näher am Bauch bei dir. Die rechte Seite. Rechts ist näher am Bauch. Du trägst seit Jahren keine Jeans mehr. Ja, eben, ich merke gerade, dass ich echt keine... Ja, aber das ist nicht so. Aber auf der rechten Seite ist der Knopf und auf der linken Seite ist das Loch. Ja, genau. Richtig. Und du machst ja dann ...
Genau, und so macht das auch Sinn.
Und jetzt mit dem Links- und Rechtsträger, das glaube ich nicht so ganz, aber das macht man schon auch so ein bisschen. Einerseits, was war zuerst da? Wurden die Hosen so geschnitten und dadurch wurden Männer Linksträger oder sie sind Linksträger und deswegen ... Weiß ich nicht. Kann sein. Kann beides sein. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Oh, was hast du Ostern gemacht? Ah, jetzt, wir kommen zum grossen Ei im Raum, dem Oster-Talk. Ja, Leute, es ist passiert. Es war wieder Ostern. Ich liebe Ostern, das ist einfach das beste Fest. Wir haben Eier gesucht. Ja, war unspektakulär, Feiertage, ich bin kein Fan von Feiertagen. Ich mag es nicht, wenn die Welt stillsteht, ich mag, wenn die Welt brummt und bebt und da was passiert.
Ich bin neuerdings ein Fan. Seitdem ich festangestellt bin, bin ich ein Fan von Feiertagen. Wow, ich liebe Frohnleichnam, genial, ich liebe Pfingsten, Pfingsten ist super, ich liebe, was gibt es noch, 1. Mai, wow, und natürlich Ostern, geil. Ich habe mir Urlaub genommen, vor und danach und war eine Woche weg.
Bei mir hat es ein bisschen das Gefühl, die Ostertraditionen wandeln sich. Ostern, geil. Ich habe mir Urlaub genommen, vor und danach und war eine Woche weg.
Bei mir hat es ein bisschen das Gefühl, die Ostertraditionen wandeln sich.
Also die Traditionen bauen ja aufeinander auf und ich habe das Gefühl, es ist mittlerweile eine grössere Tradition geworden,
zu betonen, dass man nicht weiß, worum es an Ostern geht, als die tatsächlichen Ostertraditionen. Das ist die neue Tradition, ständig zu betonen, was soll das eigentlich, auch Hase und Jesus, was soll das. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,. Ja, kann gut sein. Das ist wirklich aber auch ein bisschen verwirrend alles. Da haben wir uns aber auch schon vor acht Jahren, du warst nicht gemacht, in diesem kleinen Podcast, das war, ist natürlich immer wieder eine Frage, wie das alles zustande kommt.
Ich glaube, die echte Lösung ist, dass ein Arzt den Osterhasen erfunden hat.
So ein bisschen der Arzt ist, das Coca-Cola, was Coca-Cola für Weihnachtsmann ist, ist ein Arzt für den Osterhasen, der irgendwann diesen Begriff geprägt hat, um, glaube ich, einfach Kinder zu verwirren.
Und diese Aufstehungssache, ich glaube, da hat die Kicher auch gesagt, komm, wir brauchen was Größeres, was ist nämlich verdeckt so ein bisschen, weil das glaubt uns niemand mehr. Glaube ich, weiß ich nicht genau. Aber Jesus ist schon der Einzige bei den grossen Religionen, der stirbt, oder? Bei den Top vier ist Jesus, nee. Die anderen, also jetzt sagen wir mal die Messias-Figuren, also Ra bei den alten Ägyptern, Mesmo bei den alten Etruskern, Smisma. Maja bei den Imkern. Genau, man muss sagen. Maja ist nie gestorben. Ich glaube, Jesus ist der einzige, das ist ja schon ganz geil, dass wir die einzige Story haben, wo die Hauptfigur stirbt. Nee, aber hier bei den Muslimen. Nee, der geköpft hat er? Nee, ich glaub, der ist aber auch ... Klar, der ist doch ... Man darf ja auch kein Bild von dem malen. Ja, weil der so heilig ist und so, aber nicht weil der gestorben ist. Ich glaub, wir haben die einzige Story, wo die Hauptfigur ... Das ist doch geil, wir haben so das Game of Thrones der Religionen, wo mal irgendwie Blut fließt, wo mal irgendwas passiert, wo sagt so, oh nein, schafft er es oder nicht, oh, er ist am Kreuz,
wie schafft er es da wieder rauszukommen, mit einem Magneten
versucht er die Festplatte zu...
Wohingegen die Buddhisten wirklich ein Problem haben, weil die haben das
Was ist eine Serie, die niemals
endet? Hm, die haben das Big Bang Theory
der Religion. Das stimmt.
Was ist der Islam?
Ist, hm, ach, irgendeine
Ramsch-Serie.
Ich kenne mich nicht gut mit dem Islam. So eine Soap. Ja, aber, nee, ganz im Ernst, dieses immer wiedergeboren werden als Ameise und dann kommt man als Falter wieder. Nicht Ameise, Ameise. Ameise. Nein, ohne R, Ameise. Die Armen, das kommt von den Armen. Die hat die Ameise. Das ist wie eine Meise und die haben grosse Arme. Die haben keine grossen... Ich finde, die heißt eine Armeise! Genauso wie der Nasenbär, wenn der keine grosse Nase hat. Nasenbär! Mein Gott, von... Kriegt man seine Fakten richtig, Jens? Wie dieser Forscher, der sagt, Nasenbär, ich finde, der hat gar keine so grosse Nase. Ich finde schon, dass der eine grosse Nase hat, der ist jetzt Nasenbär. Der unterbriefen heißt Ameisenbär, aber der ist doch keine Ameisen. Ich finde, das könnte er doch. Der könnte die gut essen mit seinem Rüssel. Rotkehlchen, das ist auch ein bisschen orange. Ich finde, das ist rot. Diese Person hat sämtliche Gegenstände der Welt. Eisvogel. Müssen wir darauf eingehen? Was ist ein Eisvogel? Ja, Problem. Ich bin ein bisschen traumatisiert von Eisvögeln. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich diese Geschichte schon erzählt habe. Als Kind, wir haben einen Teich zu Hause. Einen grossen, grossen Teich im Garten. Und als Kind stand ich lange am Fenster und hab, hey, hier willst du nicht reinkommen in diesen Raum.
Und dann hab ich eine Zeit lang auf diesen Teich geschaut und dann war plötzlich, kam so ein Dachteich. Und dieses Rotkehlchen hat sich auf den Zaun gesetzt vom Teich, da war ein Zaun drum, da würde ich nicht reinfallen, weil ich ein Trottel war. Und dann hat er plötzlich so ein bisschen sich umgeschaut und plötzlich hat er aufgestiegen und in den Teich gestürzt und hat einen Fisch gegessen. Da waren Fische drin in dem Teich? Massive Fische und kleine Babyfische. Der hat einen dieser Babyfische genommen und ist zerfetzt, in der Luft durchgebissen. Ich dachte mir, wow, das sind Rotkehlchen, die machen so was nicht. Stell dir raus, das ist ein Eisvogel. Fiese Dinger, die ein Eisvogel sind und die eigentlich bei uns gar nicht existieren dürfen, die magisch selten sind und so. Ich weiß nicht, warum die Eisvögel heißen, aber die sehen ein bisschen aus wie Rotkehl. Ich finde, die sehen aus wie so eine Eistüte. Nein, ich fände schon. Trotzdem. Wir machen, lass das jetzt so. Ja, das war traumatisiert, auf jeden Fall. Was gibt es so für Tiere, wo man nicht genau weiß, warum die so heißen? Also viele Tiere. Gürteltier. Blaubeer. Was für ein Arschloch, wie fucking dominant Menschen einfach sind und wie sie ihre fucking Dominanz einfach raushängen lassen. Gürteltier, dieses Tier seit Jahrmillionen lebt, es zieht Kinder auf, hat irgendwie tolle Erlebnisse. Ja, wir machen Gürtel draus, also Gürtel. Ja, aber jetzt guck mal, die haben einen tollen Panzer,
die haben irgendwie ein ganz interessantes Privatleben. Ich finde die
sehen aus wie ein Gürtel.
Einfach so ein Gürteltier.
Das ist schon echt... Auch Schildkröten,
dass man die, einfach, dass man da sagt,
dass man die einfach mit diesen Kröten in so einen Topf
wirft, aber seitdem ist es ein Schild.
Es ist halt nicht mal im Ansatz eine Kröte,
es ist eher so etwas wie eine Eidechse. So etwas ganz anderes, oder? Eidechse und Kröten? Panzerdechse, könnte man sagen, finde ich. Oder Panzerinchen. Also man kann sich auch ganz neue Begriffe aufdacht. Du verniedlichst nur alle Tiere. Vögelchen. Habe ich mir auch letztens gedacht beim Gänseblümchen, wie assid es ist, dass das so ein Diminutiv bekommt, so von wegen Blümchen, wow, wow, wow, wow, Sonnenblume und Sonnenblümchen. Technisch gesehen bin ich auch eine Blume. Du bist ein Blümchen! Warum Blümchen? Das stimmt, das stimmt. Gänseblümchen, Gänseblume, wäre aber auch ein bisschen. Ganz, ganz Blume. Gänse, Gänseblume. Gänseblümchen. Aber manche Sachen sind einfach diminutiv, so wie Mädchen. Da kannst du auch nicht sagen, Mäd. Made. Das ist der alte Gag. Ach so. Was man sagt, wenn Jung... Ne, wenn Jung... Alles, was mit Mädchen zu tun hat, Steffans Gehirn einfach Shutdown-Mode, Emergency-Mode. Weißt du, man hat zu wissen kein gutes Gedächtnis. Ich habe Dinge, die vergesse ich dann auch ganz schnell wieder, einfach weil ich glaube, dass ich die nie wieder brauche. Und dann fällt mir in so einem Podcast, in so einem Laber-Podcast, den man dann doch hat, fällt einem auf, dass man so etwas vielleicht mal merken sollte. Aber manche Dinge merke ich mir nicht. Deswegen schreibe ich mir die mal auf, wenn mir Dinge passieren, dass ich die nicht vergesse, auch wenn es furchtbare Dinge sind, die mir passieren. Ich war abends, über Ostern war ich in den Staaten, in den US of A, bin ich wieder rüber geflogen. Über Manchester bin ich nach Orlando geflogen. Es kommt die Manchester Story. Die Manchester Story. Leute, spitzt die Puffopedia, es wird wieder heiß.
Man fliegt über Manchester, man fliegt nach Manchester nicht einfach mit einem normalen Flugzeug, wie man das kennt, nein, man fliegt mit einem Propellerflugzeug, wie man das aus den Nachrichten kennt. Dieses typische Propellerflugzeug, was man abgestürzt, oft einfach nicht ganz im ganzen Zustand irgendwo in Bergmassiven sieht. und es ist toll also man hat das man fühlt sich auch viel zu verbunden zu seinem flugzeug weil ich
da zum beispiel ganz im ganzen Zustand irgendwo in Bergmassiven sieht. Und das ist toll. Also man hat das, man fühlt sich auch viel zu verbundener zu seinem Flugzeug. Weil ich sah zum Beispiel die Reifen. Das ist ein tolles Gefühl, wenn du die Reifen siehst, das kleines Flugzeuges. Weil du denkst dann, wow, cool, das Flugzeug ist kein Wunderwerk, das ist einfach genau wie dein Auto, das sind Reifen, der nicht so toll aufgepumpt ist. Cool, es ist so menschlich alles plötzlich. Und dann fährt man los und dann eiert das so ein bisschen und man denkt, geil, wow, das ist ja alles gar nicht so Wunderwerk. Und dann landet man und man setzt auf und dann landet man wieder. Das ist total klasse. Man muss so Schwung holen, man muss so wie so ein Dreisprung, so Bounce, Bounce und wie Super Mario, so ein Dreisprung. Und dann geht das los, ja. Ja, ganz toll. Und dann landet man und der rollt ja nicht sofort los, sondern der bleibt, ich komme erst zum Qualmen, weil das natürlich erstmal über den Boden ratscht und bis es dann anfängt auch zu rollen. Toll, das zu sehen. Und dann war ein Mann neben mir, ich sass links, hatte eine ganz normale Zweierreihe
und rechts neben mir war der Notausgang und ein Mann.
Und dann hat die Stewardess dem am Anfang gesagt, haben Sie kurz Zeit, dass ich den Notausgang erklären muss. Und das ist ein bisschen komplexer bei diesen kleinen Maschinen. Und dann hat die halt angefangen, dem Herrn den Notausgang zu erklären. Und man hat sich das so vorgemacht und gesagt, das ist alles nur Routine und man erklärt das und dann geht die weg. Aber der Mann hat das ernst genommen, man hat das dann nachgemacht, diese ganzen Sachen, die die Suedess ihm gezeigt hat, aber falsch. Und dann ist die über das Scheiße. Und dann hat er offensichtlich einfach komplett, er hat dann die Geste nachgemacht, ach so, wo mache ich das dann, ne? Und dann dachte ich, ja okay, cool, er will das nachmachen, aber er hat es komplett falsch gemacht und dann hat die Suedess so etwas gesagt wie, ja genau, nur ganz andersrum. Also sie müssen das, wie gesagt, mit der rechten Hand das machen. Er hat dann auch so stolz genickt und sie ist dann weggegangen.
Und dann war ich ein bisschen sauer, neben den Mordausgang zu setzen, weil ich habe dann den Mann beobachtet und er hat dann halt so genickt, während sie weggegangen ist, als ob alles klar war. Und dann, als sie weg war gerade und nicht mehr zu sehen war, weil sie irgendwie Essen geholt hat für die anderen Passagiere, hat er nochmal seine Brille aufgesetzt und ist so ganz nah an den Notausgang rangegangen, um sich jetzt durchzulesen. Und ich hab mir so fein, wir werden alle so draufgehen einfach in diesem Flugzeug, was Reifen hat, wie ein normales Auto.
Ja. dann rangegangen, um dich jetzt durchzulesen, und ich hab mich so fein, wir werden alle so draufgehen einfach in diesem Flugzeug, was Reifen hat, wie ein normales Auto. Und das war so schrecklich, das einfach zu sehen, wie der... Das ist wahrscheinlich dann in das ganze Flugzeug steht eine Flamme, und er kriegt es nicht hin und ist dann so, wie wenn man jemandem über die Schulter schaut, wenn jemand was googelt, und Google macht schon Autocomplete das ganze Ding und er tippt noch alles ein und denkt sich, mach einfach Enter so, und dann einfach aber währenddessen verbrennen alle hinter links, macht einfach auf, können Sie bitte ruhig sich, ich muss mich konzentrieren, ja, das war ganz schön furchtbar, aber dann bin ich safe angekommen und dann schön mit einem dicken Boeing nach Orlando geflogen, das ist dann geil, weil da hast du dann, weil da, das ist ganz interessant, weil dann bist du ja in deinem eigenen Reich, du bist ja auch schon mal nach Russland geflogen und du merkst ja auch in diesen großen Flugzeugen, da hast du wirklich so dein eigenes Reich, du hast ja wirklich so eine kleine Wohnung für ein paar Stunden einfach, wo du einfach um deine eigenen, du musst dir um dein Essen kümmern, du musst aufräumen manchmal, dann kommt dir der Müll, die Müllabfuhr vorbei und dann kannst du dir manchmal was geben und dann schmeißen dir das weg. Du hast Nachbarn, du hast Nachbarn, du hast so dein eigenes Reich, du hast deine eigene Entertainmentstation vor dir. Und da merke ich auch so, dass ich selbst damit nicht so ganz klarkomme mit diesen ganzen Zeiten. Weil du musst fertig essen, bis die mit dem Müllabfuhr vorbeikommt. Dann musst du es erst wegschmeißen. Dann musst du merken, darfst du auch nicht schlafen. Du musst deine Schlafzeit der programmierten Flugzeugzeit anpassen. Das heißt, die haben ja auch so ein paar Sachen, wenn du die Nacht fliegst zum Beispiel, dann haben die so ein paar Zeiten, wo die sagen, jetzt machen Sie bitte Ihre Roller hinzu und schlafen jetzt. Und ja, das haben die manchmal. Und dann zwei Stunden vor Landung wecken die einen dann wieder und dann muss man die wieder hoch machen und so. Und dann machen die Licht aus und so. Die passen ja, die bilden ja sozusagen ihre eigene Zeitzone in dem Flugzeug gerade, was ich auch spannend finde. Und da hatte ich meine Frage an euch da draußen, ob da jemanden kennt, ob da nicht Schlafforscher auch helfen, diese Zeiten festzulegen und ob es da irgendwie Möglichkeiten gibt, das Jetlag zu minimieren. Weil ich glaube, gefühlt haben die so ein paar Zeiten, wo die einfach sagen, jetzt schlafen, jetzt aufwachen, jetzt geht's Frühstück und so. Und theoretisch fliegst du durch alle Zeitzonen.
Es ist mal, du startest um 18 Uhr, landest um acht Uhr und du warst mal in jeder Zeitzone bis dahin.
Und das ist schon ein bisschen seltsam.
Und dann hab ich aber alles verschlafen.
Dann wachst du halt auf und hast so einen Berg aus Frühstück, Abendessen und massiv viel Müll vor dir liegen.
Aber das ist einfach Penta, das ist einfach schwierig.
Und Post auch noch. Und Posten, die Berechn Mahnung. Du hast eine Mahnung bekommen. Oh nein. Ja, krass. Eine Meldung für Ruhestörung von den Nachbarn. Hast du was angeschaut im Flugzeug? Es gibt so eine ganz bestimmte Art von Filmen, die man auf Flugzeugen schaut. Das ist jetzt nicht mehr so. Es gab alle Filme der Welt. Ah, okay. Aber irgendwie, nein, doch nicht. Es waren so so viele, also sehr viele Blockbuster-Gedöns, was man nicht so wirklich gern guckt. Ich hab noch mal La La Land angefangen, bin dann bei eingeschlafen und Rogue One, um mich auf die Star Wars-Stimmung zu bringen. Denn? Denn ich war bei der Star-House-Celebration 2017 in Orlando, Florida! Wow! Das war, also, das war schon ganz schön krass. Das war eine Veranstaltung, wo, also das war schon, das war ganz schön krass,
also das war eine Veranstaltung, wo 60.000
Star-Wars-Fans waren, die die ganze Zeit
an diesem Wochenende rumgelaufen sind, meistens in
Kostümen, das war so weird
und alle, man ist die ganze Zeit mit so einem
offenen Mund rumgelaufen, wo es überall was zu sehen gab
und so weiter und
es gab viele Geschichten, die könnt ihr euch alle anhören,
im anderen Podcast, im Star-Wars-Podcast,
aber es gab eine wahnsinnig lustige Situation, wo es dann, weil die Leute, muss ich mir vorstellen, die sind den ganzen Tag im Kostüm, die werden dann auch zur Rolle. Und dann gab es diesen einen Darth Vader, der halt komplett in persona war und halt wirklich auch toll aussah, toller Darth Vader. Und es war schon später an dem Tag, also man kann sich vorstellen, der ist schon den ganzen Tag in dieser 20-Kilo-Rüstung am Kopf alleine schon rumgelaufen. Und dann war der halt so ein bisschen, ja, angefressen kann man sagen. Und dann ist er halt mit grossen Vader-Schritten durch die Lobby gelaufen. Und dann wollten Kinder Fotos haben. Und es haben sich so eine Horde Kinder gebildet, die nebenher gelaufen sind. Und auch vor allem stehen geblieben sind, weil die Fotos haben wollen. Und die Mutter ist nicht dahin gelaufen, weil die die Fotos machen müssen. Und er hat die einfach ignoriert und einfach mal so weggeschoben. So quasi mit so grossen Handbewegungen, wie die mit der Macht. Hat die so aus dem Weg geschoben. Dann wie aus Magic ist er dann auch so auf so automatisch aufgehende Türen zugelaufen, die dann einfach aufgegangen sind. Und er ist weitergelaufen. Und die Kinder so, hey, können wir vielleicht ein Foto haben? Und er hat dann mit dieser verzerrten Stimmung gesagt, nein. Und ist dann weitergelaufen. Und ich dachte mir so, wow, wie gut ist das denn? Das würde der echte Vader auch machen. Das würde der echte Vader auch machen. Er war zu sehr in der Rolle. Das war der beste Cosplay an dem ganzen Wochenende. Ja, vor allem, es gibt ja auch so von so Diktatoren, so von Hitler, so Bilder, wie er dann so Fotos macht mit Kindern und so PR-mäßig. Macht Darth Vader sowas auch, um sein Imperium irgendwie im Griff zu halten? Und dann irgendwie so mit so kleinen Banter-Babys dann so streicheln irgendwie so und dann die kleinen Kinder so Hallo oder nicht. Gab's eine Vader-Jugend? Das ist eine gute Frage. Aber das war so lustig, einfach zu sehen, wie man so in der Rolle verschmilzt, dass man einfach so die Kinder wegschiebt. Das war, da gab's ganz lustige Situationen. Tolles Event, kann ich noch jedem empfehlen, wer es daraus findet, sollte auf jeden Fall. Und du hast den Trailer gesehen, als erster Mensch der Welt, zusammen mit allen anderen. Ja, das war auch ganz schön krass. Ich habe mich noch nie so gefreut in meinem Leben. Wie sehr nervt es dann, wenn Leute während dem Trailer reden? Geht so. Tatsächlich wurden die total leise alle, als es angefangen zu laufen. Und dann fing es natürlich an, dass Leute gejubelt haben an coolen Szenen. Während des Trailers, also der Trailer für The Last Jedi, der nächste Film, der im Netz zusammenkommt. Und dann sah man zum Beispiel eine Szene, wo Ray auf der Insel trainiert, und das war ein cooler, ganz offener, großer Shot, und dann sah das cool aus, und dann haben wir angefangen zu schreien und zu jubeln. Normalerweise würde mich das nerven im Kino zum Beispiel, wenn man einen Film guckt, aber wenn man so einen Trailer zusammen guckt mit so einer dreitausend Menschen, dann fand ich das schon cool. Das hat mich so sehr genervt. War auch jemand währenddessen gerade auf dem Klo oder so, da dann danach kam und meinte so, können wir es nochmal zeigen, bitte nochmal für mich, Leute! Es wurde dann nochmal gezeigt, tatsächlich, es wurde zweimal gezeigt. Ja. Ja, aber das war wirklich, das war richtig cool. Auch ein toller Trailer, muss man sagen. Ich finde ihn richtig schick. Ja, ich finde, man ist jetzt mittlerweile so ein bisschen an Force Awakens gewohnt, an diesen Look, und das sieht alles natürlich mega cool aus. Und Rogue One hat ja so viele Beauty-Shots gehabt, dass man ja fast so ein bisschen überdrüssig ist. Aber so eine Story-mässige und so ist ja natürlich cool, was da passiert. Ja, hat aber auch nichts, ist aber einfach der Trailer hat einfach auch nicht Rian Johnson gemacht, sondern einfach die Leute von Disney, die hier machen die Trailer, von daher finde ich es okay, dass der so aussieht wie Forza Aarhus. Ja, ne, völlig in Ordnung. Die gleichen Leute, die den Trailer machen. Völlig in Ordnung. Aber das sah richtig cool aus, also cooles Event, cooles Event, viele Frauen auch da, falls du da, ich sehe an deinem Blick schon, dass du jetzt, dass du wieder-Ha-Jungfrauen-Blick auf dem Gesicht hast. Da waren auch viele Frauen. Auch Al-Ray tatsächlich. Oder Leia. Oder Leia. Es waren jetzt Mitarbeiter, haben die eine Frau mehr. Die müssen sich zwischen drei Frauen entscheiden, die es im Star Wars Universum gibt. Ja, tatsächlich. Aber das war, du bist dann auch in so einer Welt und dann sitzt neben dir halt in einer Kantine, sitzt dann halt so ein Stormtrooper, der dann auch ist. Und die haben halt alle lächerlich gute Kostüme, die halt genauso aussehen, auch so ein bisschen gebraucht aussehen, nicht so wie man die kauft. Und dann haben die auch diesen Stimmenverzerrer und reden halt auch genauso wie Stormtrooper. Und dann reden die halt über, wann die nächste Show eröffnet sich und so und sitzen halt daneben hier und essen Pommes. Das ist schon cool, einfach das zu sehen. Das ist einfach ein sehr cooles Event. Da habe ich diese ironische Distanz gar nicht. Überhaupt nicht, das ist ja völlig in Ordnung. Die ihr von uns kennt und die ihr gewohnt seid und die ihr auch zurecht erwartet. Aber das war einfach zu cool. Aber alles weitere kann man dann in Antenna Alderaan hören. Der mittlerweile preisgekrönte Star Wars Podcast. Ich habe einen Deutschen getroffen und der krasseste Nerd, den ich jemals getroffen habe, der war alleine da aus Deutschland, der ist um die 40, hat seine Familie hinter sich gelassen und es war alleine in Orlando, Florida, da ist da rumgelaufen. Und den haben wir getroffen und der wusste, dass wir den Preis bekommen haben. Ja? Ja, weil das augenscheinlich in den Nerdkreisen sind diese Preise wichtig. Welchen Preis habt ihr denn bekommen? Wir haben den Preis für den besten Foreign Language Podcast bekommen. Und von wem hat er den? Von der Star Wars Union. Von der Star Wars Podcasting Union. Ich dachte, das wäre ein Juxpreis. Ich dachte, das wäre ein Scherz. Aber tatsächlich ist dieser Preis wohl renommiert in den Kreisen der Star Wars Community. Ich fände es lustig. Ich finde es cool, dass wir den bekommen haben. Und den haben wir da vorne bekommen und da wurden wir erkannt. Aber hinkt da irgendwas dran an dem Preis? Seid ihr jetzt auf irgendeiner Plakette oder irgendwas? Deswegen halte ich das für einen Juxpreis. Wir haben nicht mal eine E-Mail bekommen. Wir haben einen Tweet, beglaube ich, dass wir den Preis bekommen haben, sonst nicht. Das ist ein bisschen schade. Ich hätte auch noch richtig... Immerhin. Ey, aber am coolsten fand ich die R2-D2-Rennen, wo einfach Leute dann angefangen haben, es gibt so R2-Bilders, die hatten auch einen eigenen Stand und so, und dann haben die angefangen, aus einem grossen Areal so ein Rennen zu fahren, so verschiedene... Och, da gab es auch vorhin noch R2s rum, die hatten offensichtlich niemanden, der die steuert. Und die fuhren dann einfach da rum. Vielleicht saß er drin. Das dachte ich mir auch dann inzwischen durch. Das Antenna-Alteran ist jetzt offiziell erfolgreicher als das Podcast-Ufo. Ja. Podcast-Ufo hat noch keinen einzigen Preis bekommen. Was könnten wir denn für einen Preis bekommen? Ja, man muss sich irgendwo auch anmelden, so Grimme Online und so, da muss man sich irgendwie immer bewerben. Ja, lass uns vielleicht anfangen mit dem Grimme Online. Ja, ja. Den haben wir verdient. Den haben wir richtig verdient. Podcasting Union. Naja, das sind diese speziellen Kreise. Geht du mit deinem Das Schwarze Auge Podcast? Du hast doch bestimmt auch schon, die habt ihr auch schon Kreise bekommen, bin sicher, von denen du nicht wirst. Ne, wir sind so ein bisschen rogue, was das angeht. Wir wurden auch vom Verlag verstoßen, wir kriegen da keine Exemplare und so. Ja, es gibt auch andere Podcasts, die dann auch Verlagsexemplare bekommen, so Vorschau von den neuen Büchern und die rezensieren und so. Aber die schleimen halt auch mega und so. Wir sind halt so ein bisschen edgy, wir sagen halt auch mal, hey, die neue Edition finden wir scheiße und so und alles. Und klar, dass man dann natürlich aneckt und dann irgendwie rausfliegt und so und ja.
Ihr betrinkt euch auch, so klingt das gerade.
Nein, will es nicht sagen,
aber naja, was der Sigi da immer
treibt. Ne,
ja, mal gucken. Ich hätte auch gern
mehr Preise, sage ich ganz ehrlich.
Und dann war ich in Orlando und Orlando ist
halt vor allem bekannt durch die Freizeitparks
ja auch. Und an einem Tag war ich im Universal Park.
Es war ein lächerlich tolles Wochenende einfach, weil der Universal Park, da haben die einfach eine Harry Potter Welt und die haben eine Jurassic Park Welt und so weiter. Das ist Wahnsinn für mich gewesen. Und dann darfst du ganz einfach mit so einem offenen Mund rum und weinst vor Freude, weil du ein Butterbier trinkst neben dem Hogwarts-Schloss und so. Das ist so toll. Wie schmeckt das ein Butterbier? Das ist einfach, das ist gefühlt einfach so ein karamelliges, karamelliges Soda mit Sahne. Das ist eigentlich ganz lecker gewesen. Hast du einen Zauberstab gekauft? Ne, habe ich nicht. Der kostet 50 Dollar Bescheid. Die brauchte ich für mein Laserschwert. Und dann waren wir in diesem einen, da es diesen einen Ride, und zwar von King Kong. Das war so eine Art Geisterbahn-Exkurs und so. Die sind auch wirklich coole, coole Bahnen. Geisterbahn-Exkurs? Ja, es war so ein Busse quasi, wie so Expeditionsbusse, wo man sich reinsetzt und dann fährt man durch so eine Landschaft und so. Und dann hast du auch so VR-Welten neben dir und so weiter. Das alles stand ziemlich gut aus und dann stand man halt leider sehr lange an, zwei Stunden. So, das war natürlich hart und so. Und dann war es leider so, dass vor mir war eine mexikanische Familie in der Schlange. Und die waren offensichtlich alle sturzbetrunken und auf Kokain. Die waren, also wirklich alle, die waren so aufgedreht, alle, selbst die Mütter und die Oma, die waren so aufgedreht und so massiv, furchtbar nervig und waren auch nicht mehr so ganz bei Sinnen, die haben auch alles angefassen wollen und so und das war ganz, ganz seltsam. Die haben gerade einen riesigen Affen gesehen, die dachten, die sind in Gefahr. Und die waren, und dann haben die mich gesehen und irgendwas ist dann, irgendwie sind die Synapsen dann komplett durchgeballert und offensichtlich haben die mich für eine art haben die mich erkannt glaube ich also so eine auf eine art wie ich sehe aus wie ich glaube ich sehe aus wie ein mexikanischer filmstar oder so es tut mir leid das zu sagen weil wie jemand ist der band ist die oder wie ich sehe vielleicht sehe ich auch so aus wie jemand aus einer soap in mexico oder so weil die waren die haben plötzlich so gelacht dass Das Weisseste, was sie jemals gesehen haben. Oder ich habe einfach irgendwie Zugang bei dem Gesicht gehabt oder so. Jedenfalls haben die mich angeguckt und sich kaputt gelacht. Und davor war auch eine mexikanische Familie und die haben das gehört, mich gesehen und haben sich auch kaputt gelacht. Und das war die weirde Situation. Zwei Stunden lang wurde ich komplett ausgelacht, wirklich aber massiv die ganze Zeit. Die haben mich auf mich gezeigt und so, vielleicht war ich auch zu groß, vielleicht war ich der größte Mensch, den ich jemals gesehen habe, keine Ahnung. Und die haben gerade fucking King Kong gesehen. Ja, und die haben halt King Kong gesehen, aber King Kong war nebensächlich. Dann kam die Schlange so langsam in den Raum, wo so eine Frau von so einem Urvolk, so eine animierte Frau, bei sich da stand und massiv gruselig war, hat die nicht interessiert. Haha, da ist ein Typ, der ist wahnsinnig gross, der fand ihn lustig. Es war wirklich schlimm, zwei Stunden lang ausgelacht zu werden, und dann kam die Schlange so langsam Richtung Expeditionsbus, der dann losfuhr und cool, und dann plötzlich geht das Licht an in dem ganzen Ride, plötzlich überall geht das Licht an, und ähm ... Der ganze Bus lacht dich aus. Dann hat man eine Durchsage, ha, wissen Sie, ist? Stefan Liesel in Reihe zwei. Dann hat sich herausgestellt, dass einer dieser Busse stecken geblieben ist. Und dann ist er draußen einfach, der fuhr auch kurz nach draußen, bevor er dann reinfuhr in diese Art Geisterbahn, und der ist stecken geblieben draußen. Und da war so ein bisschen so eine Panik ausgebrochen, die in diesem Bus Busstecken geblieben sind und das ganze Gebäude wurde evakuiert. Heißt, wir standen zwei Stunden an, ich wurde zwei Stunden ausgelacht und diese Familie vor mir und ich waren halt jetzt dran, um fahren zu können und dann ist das ganze Gebäude geschlossen worden und alle mussten rausgehen. Und du bezeichnest es trotzdem als eines der schönste Wochenende deines Lebens. Richtig, weil diese Familie auch nicht fahren durfte. Ja. Das war das Beste. Das war so befriedigend. Vergiss mich, ich bin nicht gefahren. Okay, geschenkt, aber die sind auch nicht gefahren. Die standen genauso lange an. Das fand ich cool. Das ist schon immer hart mit dem Anstehen. Warum ist das so? Kann man das nicht besser organisieren? Härter ist, ja, vor allem, dann gibt es halt diese Leute mit Expresspass und die konnten dann halt an der Schlange vorbeigehen. Ah, das ist vielleicht der eigentliche Grund, ja. Ja, und das macht nämlich dann, die eigentlichen Wartenden müssen dann viel länger warten, natürlich, weil die ganze Zeit Leute reinkommen, die die ganze Zeit fahren dürfen. Und das ist halt dieser Blick auf deren Gesicht, wenn die an der Schlange vorbeilaufen, das ist so furchtbar. Allein für diesen Blick lohnt sich das zu kaufen, damit man die Leute angucken kann. Ich würde es auch machen und so. Und dann gab es in dem Hulk, dem Hulk-Fahrgeschäft, kam es dann dazu, dass es quasi so eine Schlange war, immer so rechts, links, aber wirklich so lang. Und rechts kamen die ganze Zeit Leute lang mit dieser Express-Schlange. Das heißt, die ganze Zeit wurden die durchgelassen und links war dann der Mob, zu dem ich gehörte. Und wir haben angefangen auch so zu rufen, so Buh! Und wollten dann auch rein, weil der hat dann die ganze Zeit nur die reingelassen und uns nicht. Und unsere Schlange wurde immer größer, und die waren in der Unterzahl massiv. Ich dachte mir, wenn wir jetzt in Meutereibe gehen, die haben keine Chance, die sind in der Unterzahl. Aber kamen wir nicht dazu. Aber die Stimmung war schon aufgereizt. Dann war es dann immer in Hulk-Fahrgeschäften lustigerweise. Wie wütend mit Zuckerwatte. Einfach so ein Freizeitpark. Wütend in der Achterbahn. Ja, aber es wäre echt cool. Also lächerlich schön auch alles da. Hogwarts, wow. Ganz Hogwarts oder wie? Ja, Hogwarts in Miniatur nachgebaut, aber schon ziemlich gross. Also es ist immer noch wahnsinnig gross. Es ist wie eine grosse Kirche, war der Turm gross. Auch sehr innovative Fahrgeschäfte, wo dann einfach so quasi die ganze Zeit an so einer grossen Videowand, wie angenommen, stell dir mal eine grosse Kienlewand vor, und dann sitzt du einfach da in deinem Sitz direkt davor, der fährt dann aber die ganze Zeit rum und der Film fährt mit dir und du denkst einfach, du fährst, du fliegst auf einem Besen hinter Harry und Ron hinterher. Und das war schon cool, einfach. Sie haben schon gute Ideen. Also du bist Hermine oder was? Ja, ich bin Hermine, natürlich. Man kriegt auch so eine Rolle aufgedrückt, so, guck mal, hier sind deine besten Freunde, Harry und Ron, und hier ist deine Katze. Wow, warum bin ich Hermine? Ich habe immer so Lust, um hier runterzugucken zumindest, aber auch das Ding nicht. Aber Hermine ist auch die coolste Figur. Ja. Hier, guck mal, du bist in der Zelle von Asgaban. Warum bin ich Sirius Black? Mann, alle können rumfliegen, ich sitze hier die ganze Zeit in diesem gescheitten Gefängnis rum. Übrigens, zum Thema Podcastpreis, ich will auch einen Podcastpreis, und deswegen werden Takan, Budgie und ich den ersten deutschen Harry Potter Podcast starten, Antenne Asgaba.
Nein.
Doch, wir haben beide so Mittelahnung von Harry Potter und auch so nur so semi-Interesse,
aber wir starten Podcast Antenne Asgaba.
Dann mache ich Antenne ala Bastia und lasse komplett aus. Weißt du, dann will ich aber auch noch einen Preis. Ja, das ist nicht schlecht. Wenn ihr das macht, mache ich Antenne ala Bastia. Dann gibt es einen Preis für den besten Antenne-Podcast, Antenne Award. Wir konnten vorher nicht absehen, in welche Richtung sich das entwickelt. Wie dieses Jahr auf Platz zwei, Antenne Bayern. Warum Platz? Warum Bayern? Antenne Bayern. Das ist nicht meine Alliteration. Aber ich glaube, Radio wird immer besser, je weiter man nach Süden geht. Auch letztens habe ich gesehen, dass jemand bayerisches Radio hört, und ich bin großer Verfechter von bayerischem Radio. Warum? Und auch Österreich hat sehr gutes Radio, FM4, der beste Radiosender der Welt. Ich glaube, es ist wirklich so, je weiter du nach Süden liestest, desto besser wird das Radio. Ja, Südpol, Südpol 394, mega. Ist einfach mal meine, beste Sender. Antenne Pinguin, Antenne Antarktis. Ja, hätte man sagen können, man weiß aber nicht, wo die Arktis, wo Ant und wo Arktis ist. Ja. Weiß man wirklich nicht so richtig, ne? Nee, Arktis ist oben und Antarktis ist unten. Ja, das glaube ich auch. Also Antenne Antarktis. Finde ich auch immer verrückt bei Star Wars, dass sie dann irgendwie den Todesstern anfliegen mit ihrem Millennium Falcon oder so und dass sie dann immer zufälligerweise genau richtig ausgerichtet sind. Weil im Universum gibt es ja kein oben und untenen. Das heißt, du fliegst auf deinem Planeten los, fliegst dann irgendwie nach Coruscant und bist dann halt falsch rum, wenn du den Planeten anfliegst. Man muss sich erst drehen. Aber die sind immer richtig rum. Ich verstehe, was du beim Podestern meinst, aber da kannst du ja mit Traktorstrahlen argumentieren. Dass die die automatisch richtig rumdrehen oder was? Wieso richtig rumdrehen? Du kannst auf dem Planeten doch nicht falsch rumlanden. Doch, klar. Der Todesstern ist doch auch ausgerichtet. Der Todesstern hat doch auch... Hat der eigentlich eine eigene Schwerkraft, der Todesstern? Ja, das würde nie herumschweben da drin alle. Naja, aber die können ja auch eine künstliche, dass die alle in eine Richtung gucken. Ich glaube, allein die Größe des Todessterns sieht ja schon nahe, dass das so schwer ist, dass es eine eigene Gravitation hat, oder nicht? Naja, aber wenn du jetzt da irgendwie in diesen Hangar reinfliegst vom Todesstern, dann stehen da ja irgendwie Flugzeuge auf dem Boden und so haben schon überlaufen rum, das ist ja eine Gravitationsausrichtung. Ja, stimmt. Aber wenn du jetzt mit dieser Ausrichtung wegfliegst und irgendwo anders hinfliegst, dann kann es sein, dass das andersrum ist. Nein, also ja, aber Planeten... Aber natürlich, es kommt drauf an, wo bei den Planeten du landest. Ja, du kannst ja aber auch nicht, also du kannst, wenn du die Erde anfliegst, kannst du ja auch nicht falschrum landen. Also ein Space Shuttle kann ja nicht falschrum... Falschrum auf einer Landefläche landen. Auf dem Kopf! Wie soll das denn gehen? Ja, wenn du falsch anfliegst! Wie willst du denn, Beispiel der Erde, wie willst du denn falsch anfliegen, wie willst du denn auf dem Kopf landen? Die Schwerkraft rede ich ja richtig. Das hat ja gar keinen Sinn. Du kannst doch nicht in der Erde falsch rumlanden. Da hast du schon mal Leute gesehen, die falsch rumgehen, weil sie falsch gelandet sind, beim Wiederauftreten, als sie hochgesprungen sind. Wieso das, wenn ich hoch, wenn ich hochspringe, lande ich jetzt nicht auf der Decke. Das ist mir schon klar. Aber wenn du jetzt auf einen anderen Planeten fliegst, kann es sein, dass du da falsch rum ankommst. Und dann musst du, oh, ich bin falsch rum, tut mir leid, entschuldigen Sie bitte. Beim Todesstern verstehe ich das, weil du die Hangars meinst, weil die ja senkrecht auf den Todesstern reingehen. Da verstehe ich deine Argumentation, aber nicht bei Planeten. Aber beim Todesstern würde ich das auch verziehen können, ja. Aber ich glaube, da haben die einfach künstliche Schwerkraft unten drunter. Ich kann mir einen ganzen Film vorstellen, so Staus Episode 10, weil sie sich ein bisschen verrannt, weil es eine Storyline gab, wo wir die ganze Zeit falsch rum waren. Scheiße, wir hätten eigentlich falsch rum waren. Ich schau mal so einen Film vor, der all diese Probleme anspricht, so ewig lang Exposition und der immer erklärt, das ist immer so, das erzählt Katja manchmal, dass so bei so Amateurfilmen, wo sie irgendwie oft gearbeitet hat, dass da oft so, keine Ahnung, dass die Beleuchtung irgendwie schwierig ist und die deswegen die ganze Szene unter eine Strassenlaterne verlegen mussten, aber das nicht erklären konnten im Film, warum sie unter der Strassenlaterne jetzt gerade sind und deswegen man einfach sagt, ja, Katja, sag einfach einen Satz so von wegen wie, oh, gut, dass wir jetzt unter der Strassenlaterne sind und weiter Text. Ja, auf jeden Fall hat Don Giuliani mir gesagt, dass wir jetzt endlich diesen Exposition-Satz einfach reinhauen.
Gut, dass wir jetzt unter der Straßenlaterne sind. Übrigens, ich liebe dich.
Das ist ein romantischer Film.
Du musst ja auch als Drehbuchautor musst du dich einfach sehr genau entscheiden, wann was du ansprechen willst und was nicht.
Auch so gewisse Plotholes, die du ja immer drin hast einfach.
Du musst einfach sagen, fuck, will ich jetzt 20 Sekunden investieren, um das zu erklären? Aber die Realität hat ja auch Plotholes. Tennis zum Beispiel, dass man da zählt 15, 30, 5, 40. So, natürlich hat das eine Backstory und hat eine Exposition, aber die erzählst du ja nicht vor jedem Tennisspiel. Du lässt ja nicht vor jedem Tennisspiel zwei Figuren auftreten, die irgendwie dann so einen Gang entlang wetzen oder so, und dann hast du Andrew Agassi und Steffi Graf, die erzählen, ja übrigens, das hat damit zu tun, dass das früher... Wo hast du Andrew Agassi hergeholt? So ein Tennisspieler. Ja, mega gut. Und dann hast du die beiden so in der Öffnungsszene, während die Credits von dem Tennisspiel laufen. Du musst gerade immer schnell in die Sportschublade gerutscht, so ein bisschen, in die Sportwissenschaftlache. Aber du hast ja auch nicht, während die Credits von dem Tennisspiel laufen, dann irgendwie die da rumlaufen und sagen so, ja übrigens, warum sind die Punkte eigentlich so, ja das hat irgendwas mit Kanonenkugelgrössen zu tun, dass die so mit Grammangaben und dann so wurde die so bla bla. Du hast ja auch bei normalen Sachen keine Exposition, das heißt, du musst einfach hinnehmen, dass die halt 15, 30, 40 zählen, so ja, so what. So machst du als Rehbuchautor halt auch so. Ich könnte das jetzt erklären, wenn ich wollte, aber nimm es einfach so ein bisschen. Ich glaube, da hat aber, da hat J.K. Rowling bei Quidditch so ein bisschen gemogelt, dass sie einfach ein Spiel erfunden hat, was keinen Sinn ergibt. Das sind zwei Spiele, es macht keinen Sinn. Also die können noch nicht die ganze Zeit Punkte erzielen wollen, während der Schnatz, den sie fangen, automatisch... Niemand würde doch Tore schießen, wenn du diesen einen magischen kleinen Ball einfach nur fangen müsstest. Ja, vor allem das Spielquidditch ist ein gutes Beispiel für eine Sportart, die genau so konstruiert wird, dass sie innerhalb eines Buchs oder Films perfekt dramaturgisch funktioniert. Mit, oh nein, wir liegen hinten, wir werden wahrscheinlich verlieren, oh nein, unser Held schafft eine ganz kleine Tat, den Schnatt zu fangen und hat gewonnen. Ja. So, ganz easy, so in einem Fußballspiel so, ah, Hogwarts liegt 8-0 hinten, oh, Harry Potter schießt neun Tore in den letzten drei Minuten, wir haben doch noch gewonnen. Yay. So, oh cool. Was ein bescheuertes Spiel. Ja. Ich kann niemanden schlauen, Hermine, was machst du da oben auf dem Rang, dass du da jubelst, mitjubelst, du bist schlauer als das, geh in die Bibliothek und liest ein schönes Buch, aber dieses scheiß Spoiler, die musst du dir nicht angucken, das macht keinen Sinn. Haben wir eigentlich schon mal über Real Life Quidditch gesprochen? Ja, nee, haben wir noch nicht. Es ist so geil, es ist so gut, es läuft ein grosser, das klingt alles wie aufgeladen, aber es gibt es wirklich, es läuft ein grosser, als Schnatz verkleideter Mensch rum, der der Schnatz ist. Nee, der ist nicht der Schnatz, der hat den Schnatz. Ja, ich weiß. Und zwar so hinten an seinem Gürtel, hinten hat er so einen Schnatz hängen. Das heißt, erwachsene Menschen rennen hinter diesem Typen her und versuchen, ihn praktisch an den Arsch zu greifen, während er wegrennt. Der Traum eines Pädophilen, eine Quidditch-Mannschaft aufzumachen und Abtaster am Flughafen. Das ist, glaube ich, richtig krass. Ich hab da auch einen alten Mann in Manchester erwischt, der hat mir aber ordentlich dahin gelangt. Das war ganz schön unangenehm. Da dachte ich auch kurz danach, wurde ich jetzt vergewaltigt? Aber er hat auch davor extra seine Handschuhe ausgezogen, dass er sich so komplett abtastet und dann dafür die Handschuhe auszieht. Er hat Seife in die Hand gemacht, seine Hose runtergezogen und dann Handschuh ausgezogen und mir in den Schritt gefasst, massiv.
Aber war schön. So nah kam ich einem Menschen noch nie. Habt ihr noch Kontakt eigentlich? Ja, wir haben uns nur mal ausgetauscht. Schön. Also, Quidditch ist wirklich, und dann hat er da hinten so einen Schweif, glaube ich, den man fangen muss. Schaut euch das mal an, irgendwie gebt mal bei YouTube ein Real-Life-Quidditch-Match und das ist unglaublich lächerlich. Ja, das war Stefan Tietze in Amerika aus Orlando.
Für alles weitere könnt ihr Antenne-Alteran hören, um euch die ganzen Insider-Stories anzuhören und wahrscheinlich auch eine Trailer-Analyse und all das.
Ja, klar, ihr kennt das, ihr kennt das, ihr wisst, was ihr bekommt.
Ansonsten Podcast-Ufus wieder zurück aus der Osterpause.
Es geht wieder weiter, heiter, weiter, steuern wir auf die Hunder zu, da könnt ihr euch mal gefasst machen, das wird fantastisch.
Bis dahin wünschen wir euch eine wunderschöne Woche. Bis dahin, macht's gut.
Macht's gut, ciaoiii.
Ciaoiii, wir heben ab.